yeah that uh where did you get that yeah
yeah yeah
well i just noticed she like she answers
herself she's actually trying
to say she goes she yeah yeah i'm very
politically correct
yeah but she'll be like yeah so i went i
bought some jimmy choos yeah yeah
and i called my star yeah so she like i
think she spends a lot of time alone
maybe and she's
yeah crazy answering herself what is
going on with her voice because
she didn't have that voice when she was
bruce it's a different voice
is it i thought it was like pretty
similar it's like what's different it's
a little higher or something
it's like numb like her face is numb
over there yeah baby yeah
well brush i thought she was i watched
you did you see your show i am kate
she had like a reality show which bombed
i mean how
how much of a boring person you have to
be when how
interesting is like an ex-olympic
athlete turns into a woman
and you're so boring still no one wants
to see that show
yeah she needed a better producer it
seems like you put her in
interesting situations that's she's
going forward she was boring like i
watched it i tried to watch it
it was boring god i feel like there's i
just feel like they've missed the
formula like that is a
fascinating situation somebody waits
until they're 60 years old
and then becomes a man yeah how could
that show not
do well how could it i think what
happened was she wasn't
open about what her transition it wasn't
about that oh
she didn't really talk about you know
she's interesting
she doesn't believe in gay marriage that
that's when i like i was on her side and
they're like yeah
she's uh you know why not support her i
mean
what how she said well i'm kind of a
traditional watcher yeah i'm a
traditional girl
yeah and ellen is a very
maybe one of the wittiest people very
witty and she
went like this well how uh she was
completely lost for words
yeah because it's it makes no sense it's
well ellen held her feet to the fire and
their big feet she
she she burned those feet i held my 17
jimmy choos to the fire baby
yeah you got to order those custom right
oh yeah
no way around sure i i um
yeah for her to be against any group
that
yeah she's been she knows what it feels
like to be shunned or
yeah unbelievable it's just crazy she's
just decided that she's a woman
yeah a republican woman oh lesbians grow
[Laughter]
but she's a lesbian now yeah but now i
date men baby does she
or she's dating a trans
jesus so confused exhausted what is
happening
imagine if you were a man okay and then
you became a woman
and you dated a woman who became a man
what in the [ __ ] is happening you're
like
you're like one of those yin-yangs
spinning through space
yeah and then you're like gay marriage
is gross like i'm gonna judge that
it's it's they need to cut her brain
open
and and figure out what's what's going
on there's a lot of confusion
and a lot of wanting to fit in and a lot
of you know
it just doesn't make any sense and i
really like people going through that
and i i don't want to you know hurt
anyone's feelings i really just think
she's
she's kind of an [ __ ] oh this is
her girlfriend girlfriend oh so the
girlfriend used to be a boy too
yes fascinating that is wow
wait a minute girlfriend used to be a
boy that's what she used to look like
oh christ the world is so strange
and then she's like i just
she's not a great person i mean she
killed that lady with her car and then
said nothing
like uh that was the weird did you see
the footage no
she it looks completely like her fault
she bumped into this lady
who was stopped and the lady went across
traffic and and died
yeah and no one talked about it like i
was you know putting on some
my lancome in the mirror didn't share is
that what she said
no i think she was looking at her phone
yeah i don't want to see this uh
i'm going to feel bad some poor lady
died and
no one no one gives a [ __ ] because the
story is not that the story is she's a
woman now
she's always been a woman she's always
been a woman i mean it was good
timing for her because people like
ignored that and sort of went
well it's crazy timing